la musique trop son chemin jusqu'à nous
depuis le début de la pandémie
le sm et son directeur artistique kent
nagano veux le dire merci à tous les
héros de la première ligne la ligne de
front il nous offre la sicilienne de
gabriel fauré 9 à présent prêt comporte
en ces temps difficiles
alors on se laisse sur cet entretien
avec maestro nagano il nous parle
d'espoir du pouvoir de la musique du
refuge qu'elles représentent malgré
l'annulation de la saison de l'asm à
montréal
et tout ça c'est juste pour nous faire
du bien on écoute maestro nagano
bonsoir maestro nagano depuis paris
bonsoir vous êtes confinés comme des
millions de gens
entouré de votre famille votre femme et
votre fiction musicienne j'aimerais
savoir comment vous vivez ce confinement
là le vivez vous difficilement
bon je crois que c'est un peu un peu à
ploemeur l'autre sens qu'est ce que
c'est normal
aujourd'hui on partage le même
expérience avec tout le reste du monde
et on essaie quand même malgré tout les
difficultés autour tous les tragédies ou
tour quand même on essaie de rester
assez positive été voir certain que le
fait d'avoir du temps ensemble qu'en
famille et c'est vraiment un moment
riche
au spi dans une lettre publiée dans la
presse le 27 mars vous avez voulu
nourrir cet éternel espoir qu'on doit
garder
reste que aujourd'hui moins de 24 heures
après l'annoncé de l'annulation de votre
dernière saison de l'ouest tout a été
annulé bien sûr est-ce que vous
vous vous résignez difficilement ou pas
heureusement on a eu pendant ces
dernières saisons beaucoup l'expérience
ensemble
je dois dire que le plus grande chose
que on a tous entendu été un moment
vraiment célébrer ensemble cette
formidable relation tout le travail
qu'on a fait ensemble
tuez les tous et nous avons partagé
ensemble et de temps en temps quand même
les succès sont venus vraiment très très
difficile
évidemment cette célébration maintenant
ça peut pas être comme prévu à la fin de
mai ou au début de juin mais on trouve
un autre moment quand même c'est pas
possible
après tout cette amitié tout cette
confiance qu'on a partagé pendant tous
au lieu de tout simplement dit minimum
bloquant même on va trouver un autre
moment de correctement
j'étais cette seconde collaboration
on paie pas sa grande collaboration mais
certains diraient sa grande communion
avec les montréalais et l'ensemble des
québécois au fil des expériences dans ce
n'est merveille publié en 2000 qu'est ce
que vous avez co écrit un métro à nagano
vous faites un grand plaidoyer pour la
musique le pouvoir l'influencé même de
la musique sur le cerveau dites nous
quel est justement ce pouvoir de la
musique en temps de pandémie
c'est surtout des expériences qui ont
tous partagé maintenant qu'on a une
chance de renouveler affirmé de vraiment
encore une fois souligné de très très
spécial qualité de la musique et je
parle pas uniquement de musique
classique mais toute la musique c'est
musique classique est quand même moins
de normal parce que on a vu pendant
toute l'histoire
que ces musiques là c'est pas du tout
lié avec face fassions la mode du temps
c'est quelque chose qui qui va au dessus
de du temps et c'est toujours fidèle un
lifetime partners
si vous voulez c'est très fiable pour le
moment le plus grave possible on a vu ça
dans l'histoire passée en commun tenon
est très très grande moment du challenge
est aussi au moment le plus hot de joie
aussi musique et est toujours là aussi
au moment de tels seuils d isolation et
je crée autour beaucoup de nos voisins
souffre de sympathie vraiment maintenant
après plusieurs semaines d corentine
c'est émotionnellement ccico logiquement
pas toujours difficile toujours facile
la musique est là et ça allume nos
mémoires ça allume le présence parce
qu'on vive quand même maintenant et ça
car d'une certaine façon de donner toute
lumière vers la future musique fait ça
parce que dans plusieurs sens c'est une
sorte de perfection et d'avoir quand
même collaborateurs comme un campagne
comme un partenaire pour la vie c'est si
vraiment quelque chose exceptionnelle et
on peut toucher ça au moment où le nord
comme que maintenant nous dans la
famille on profite beaucoup en fait part
dans la musique on discute
malgré le fait qu'on a on continue notre
vie normale comme la plupart des gens ma
fille qui assistent l'université quand
plusieurs écoles et plus notre matière
nem on a adapté rapidement au système
online titine et ça fonctionne très bien
c'est pas la même chose que qu'un vrai
des transactions entre professeurs
étudions mais quand même c'est quelque
chose d'autre et c'est possible de
transmettre des communautés et c'est la
même chose qu'on essaie aussi par le smt
utiliser autre façon dq militer
communiquer et de partager et nous il
faut avoir confiance en nous mêmes
surtout confiance à notre communauté
québécois qui est tellement créative le
thermos pontone de trouver quand même
des solutions au moment le plus
difficile mais sont à gagner ce prêt si
vous avez évoqué la maternelle c'est la
musique aux enfants votre petite
maternelle de montréal-nord ce qu'on
prend donc vous continuer d'accompagner
les enfants avec la musique parce que la
musique est important pour les enfants
ça demande beaucoup pendant la pandémie
qu'est ce qu'on doit dire aux enfants
pour leur faire comprendre et vous et je
crois que vous êtes que la musique bon
ça rassemble ça fait tomber des murs
c'est la langue la plus universelle qui
soit exactement et si on pense un moment
pour où les enfants de l'école nationale
ils sont quatre en cinq ans alors pour
les gens de contrat c'est foutu et
sociale aussi ouverture émotionnel en
ouverture intellectuelle et bien sûr un
mode d'expression pour chaque individu
alors que d'un jour à l'autre
arrêtez ça ça va être vraiment inquiète
énorme c'est pour ça que j'admire j'ai
mis à noter qu' à la médiane alors parce
qu'ils ont rapidement adapté une autre
600 pris mon temps dans deux ou trois
jours ils ont construit une autre forme
de transe musique est comme ça les
enfants ne sont pas abandonnées toujours
dans cette merveille votre plaidoyer
pour la musique était de dire faut que
chacun trouve son chemin vers la musique
pendant l'impression qu'avec cette
pandémie c'est la musique qui trouve son
chemin vers nous comme vos musiciens ont
mis sur les réseaux numériques on en a
diffusé quelques extraits
mais aussi cette importante est ce qu'on
choisit ce qu'on veut écouter
moi je sais que vous avez trouvé
dans beethoven l'espérance que bach
c'est un de vos compositeur fétiche et
vous êtes que ces grands compositeurs
ont accompagné notre civilisation les
grands moments de l'histoire en cette
pandémie mondiale planétaire qui dont on
dit qu'ils auront une après on ne sait
pas ce ne sera pas le savourer tout va
changer
est ce qu'un compositeur qui vous émeut
qui vous inspirent davantage en ce
moment c'est intéressant parce que juste
aujourd'hui j'ai passé l'après midi avec
ma femme de examiner le mouvement los
amates ravir sonates de beethoven
cette fameux clavier sénateurs je ne
sais pas combien de fois j'ai entendu je
ne sais pas combien de temps j'ai essayé
des choux et de moi même et on a étudié
au plus profond aux profondeurs
le mouvement long ma femme m'a dit que
c'était une journée une sorte de passage
au voyage spirituel et c'est tout à fait
vrai mais aussi certaines de chance de
redécouvrir des oeuvres quand même qu'on
ait vous connais presque par coeur
dessin la chose magique et très
extraordinaire de la musique classique
et salaires est ce pas unanimes ça reste
très actif reste toujours aux
profondeurs compte chaque fois qu'on
revient avec autre perspective
et il faut dire que aujourd'hui quand on
a vu certains cependant le contexte est
très différent que ce qu'on a vu à des
niveaux et tout d'un coup on a accès au
haut niveau
on en a eu avant un bts très très
spécial pour moi
[Musique]
à
aussi aux consommatrices qui habitent
avec nous maintenant j'y suis exposé aux
autres voix du jazz notamment la
subtilité du jazz
quand même j'ai pas toujours le temps d
écouter autres genres de la musique
alors ça donne aussi maintenant chance
de voir la grande variété et est tout
simplement explorer exploration et
active et on peut faire ça ce professeur
en groupe on peut faire ça en isolation
mon peu façon collective alors c'est
juste encore un exemple
quelle nuit profonde ce spectacle
musique est un terminal maestro nagano
vous nous offrez avec une quarantaine de
musiciens l'a6 et la cécilienne de forêt
pourquoi avoir choisi cette oeuvre que
signifie-t-elle pour vous et vous
musiciens mais ça c'est encore une fois
pour moi
une affirmation de la créativité de l'om
comme alençon comme comme une équipe où
m
aboudou avec tous nos coeurs et aux
profondeurs de tous nos émotions
remercier les gens qui bat sur la
première ligne
c'est terrible virus connus ou ce serait
d'ailleurs les médecins les infirmières
les gens qui vraiment ne risquent leur
vie et on a choisi le sicilienne est le
contenu de cette cécilienne le mouvement
le mouvement de coeur le mouvement de
l'émotion le calme dans une forme de
perceuses et vraiment c'est quand que
les infirmières les médecins tout ce
groupe qui travaille sans arrêt pour
nous c'est ça ce qui l amène à nous sont
et confort inspectent ce qu'ils étaient
on a voulu comme un collectif dit un
grand grand mercier pour les gens qui
travaillent
nous dans la communauté la team elles
sont à gagner
merci nous avons parlé depuis votre
confinement à paris avec votre famille
avec l'espoir de vous revoir avec votre
baguette en main pour votre grand
concert d'adieu pour le moment l'algérie
classique ça continue le grand concert
au stade également on verra mais peu
importe le moment peu importe la date
peu importe la saison on sera au rendez
vous merci beaucoup maestro nagano
mais je suis revenu très bientôt
non
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
il
non
du fond du coeur nous vous remercions
pour tout ce que vous faites chaque
minute pour qu'on soin de nous
merci à vous tous